I’m working on the ethics and governance
of artificial intelligence project, here at
Berkman Klein.
There are a lot of questions as to how exactly
incorporating this new technology into different
social environments is really going to affect
people, and I think one of the most important
things is getting people’s perspectives
who are actually going to be impacted.
So, I’m looking forward to participating
in some early educational initiatives and
some discussions that we can post online in
blog posts and things, to help people feel
like they’re more familiar with this subject
and more comfortable, because it can be really
intimidating.
Right now, this technology or early versions
of machine learning and artificial intelligence
applications are being used in institutions
ranging from the judicial system, to financial
institutions, and they’re really going to
impact everyone.
I think it’s important for people to talk
about how they’re being implemented and
what the consequences of that are for them,
and that we should have an open discussion,
and that people can’t do that if they’re
unfamiliar with the technology or why it’s
being employed.
I think that everyone needs to have at least
a basic familiarity with these things because
in ten years there’s not going to be an
institution that doesn’t use it in some
way.
I grew up in a pretty low income community
that didn’t have a lot of access to these
technologies initially, and so I was very
new to even using a computer when I got into
college.
It’s something that was hard for me initially,
but that I started really getting interested
in, partially because I’m a huge sci-fi
fan now, and so I think that sci-fi and fiction
really opens up your eyes to both the opportunities
and the potential costs of using different
advanced technologies.
I wanted to be part of the conversation about
how we would actually approach a future where
these things were possible and to make sure
that we would use them in a way that would
benefit us and not this scarier, more dystopian
views of what could happen.
Software, so scalable, that we can offer more
resources and more information to so many
more people at a lower cost.
We’re also at a time where we have so much
more information than we’ve ever had in
history, so things like machine learning and
artificial intelligence can really help to
open up the answers that we can get from all
of that data and maybe some very non-intuitive
answers that people just have not been able
to find themselves.
I think that the thing that scares me most
is that artificial intelligence software is
going to be employed in institutions and around
populations that don’t understand both ends
of the things it has to offer, but also its
limitations.
It will just be taken as objective fact or
a scientific opinion that you can’t question,
when it’s important to realize that this
is something that is crafted by humans, that
can be fallible, that can be employed in different
ways and have different outcomes.
I think my biggest fear is that we won’t
question it and that these things will just
be able to be deployed without having any
kind of public dialogue or pushback if it
has negative consequences.